police in India are facing criticism for
a heavy-handed response to students
protesting a new citizenship law the
citizenship Amendment Act provides a
pathway to Indian citizenship for
religious minorities from neighboring
countries with the exception of Muslims
students at Delhi's Jamia Millia Islamia
University parts of which were ransacked
by police are among many across the
country that have joined in protests
against the law images like these have
sparked outrage in India baton wielding
police snatch a student their excess of
force only stopped when confronted with
incredible bravery part of what eye
witnesses say was a day of violence
against students it culminated in
officers firing teargas on protesters
inside the Jamia Millia Islamia
University in Delhi before raiding the
campus but it came out to the opposite
the police started beating us and
abusing us the aftermath in the library
speaks to the chaos scores were injured
please send out a public relations
officer to clean up the mess when we
started pushing the protesters back from
the road stones were pelted from both
sides so tear gas was used at that time
the rowdy elements went inside the
university and the police chased them in
there because a lot of stone pelting was
going on we're doing a thorough
investigation a sit-down protest
opposition leaders blame the government
for the heavy-handed response the
government has attacked students by
entering universities so we will fight
for the Constitution of India
we have said it time and again that we
will fight against the government
hostility to the citizen law keeps
gathering steam across India in West
Bengal firebrand leader Mamata Banerjee
led protests
critics say the Act which grants a route
to citizenship for non Muslim migrants
threatens India's secular foundation but
perhaps it will be the sign of unrest
spreading among student bodies that will
give Narendra Modi's government most
cause for concern and the variance of
these protests has prompted India's
Prime Minister Narendra Modi to respond
on Twitter he called the outcry
unfortunate and deeply distressed
distressing he assured people that no
Indian has anything to worry regarding
this act he also added that this is the
time to maintain peace unity and
brotherhood and joining me now a South
Asia Director of Human Rights Watch
Meenakshi Ganguly Miss goggly Prime
Minister Modi has appealed for calm in
the midst of these violent protests do
you think the extent of the opposition
has caught the government by surprise I
do hope that that is the case the Prime
Minister now recognizes that there is
public opinion against this and that he
does the right thing in in in reversing
these policies you know democracy it's
very important for her for a for an
elected leader the heat protests instead
of threatening protesters or making this
about politics but do you think that
these protests that we are seeing across
the country represent the large majority
view on the citizenship Amendment Act it
is hard to tell that the question really
is that there has been a very
significant number of voices students
who were out on the streets they the
government has made different remarks on
this issue
initially it was all about you know
trying to control immigration which of
course is a is also a problematic
because it is immigration trying to
control immigration based on religion
but the bigger concern really is how
this amendment bill is tied to a
national citizenship process now what
happens in a citizenship verification
process is that if a non-muslim cannot
produce the paperwork they will
automatically be granted citizenship
while a Muslim would not be able to now
in a country where we know for a fact
that paperwork is extremely hard to
produce this this leads to concerns that
a significant chunk of India's
population may be denied citizenship and
that really is the basis for the protest
now the government needs toward a very
clearly enunciated policies and to
understand that people are objecting to
this kind of violation of the
Constitution but what about the form of
objection there has been a lot of
violence police officers have also been
injured in these protests what would you
say to that mm-hmm well of course we
would call upon all protesters to only
engage in peaceful protest and not
engage in violence but there are other
issues involved here the culture of
street violence unfortunately has been
building up for some time largely led in
fact by BJP supporters this has been the
time when you know when BJP supporters
have gone and vandalized movie theaters
or or author's readings or you know
targeted production of movies or worse
when they have actually attacked Muslims
on the street claiming that they were
illegally trading in beef or attacked
people who they accuse of love jihad now
this kind of street violence and with
little anti violence we have been saying
for the longest time is something that
needs to be contained this culture has
come in because because the BJP has
refused to act against the supporters
when they were engaged in this kind of
violence now the same thing is
running here there are numerous
protestors also saying that they did not
commit the violence it was done by BJP
supporters separately to make them look
bad now it's hard to tell in any any of
these circumstances what exactly has
happened but certainly what should
happen is is is a is a calming of
situation a fair investigation and for
the for the BJP leadership and
particularly the prime minister who is
after all the prime minister of all of
India to to come out not engage in
politics and and recognize that there is
no shame in a democracy when leaders
listen to people's voices and reverse
course right I mean actually I knew
that's why we leave it for the time
being thank you so much for speaking to
us